In this diagram we have two
arcs centered at point p.
Arc AB.
And you could imagine
this arc could
be part of a circle like this
that is centered at point AB.
And then you have
this larger arc
cd that would be part of a
larger circle, just like that,
centered at point P.
And we don't know the
actual angle measure
of angle P. Right over here.
But without even
knowing that, just
knowing the lengths of
these segments here,
I want to think about
whether we can figure out
the ratio of the length
of arc AB, not angle AB,
to the length of arc--
I'll do that in green-- CD.
And I encourage you to pause
this video now and think
about this on your own.
Well, they didn't give us
the radian measure here,
or any type of
angle measure here,
but let's just imagine
that it is x radians.
We've already seen that one
way to think about an angle
measure in terms of
radians is that this
is a count of the number
of the length of the arc
that it intercepts
in terms of radii.
So if this has an angle
measure of x radians
then that means
that this arc length
is going to be x
times the radius.
It's going to be x radii long.
The radii is 5
units long so this
is going to be 5-- I'll
do that in that, this
is the right color-- this is
going to be 5x units long.
Well, same argument for this
arc length right over here.
It has a radius of 9.
5 plus 4.
And so this is going
to be x radii long.
Each radius is 9 units.
So it's going to
be 9x units long.
So what's the ratio
of these two lengths?
Well, the smaller arc AB
would have a length of 5x.
Arc CD would have
a length of 9x.
So the ratio is 5 to 9.
Now let's say someone says,
oh, that was pretty good,
you were able to
figure out this ratio.
Let's say we were to give
you one of these lengths.
Let's say that they were to tell
you that the length of arc AB
is 25/8.
Given that, what else could
you figure out about it?
Well, you could
actually figure out
everything else you
would want to know.
You could figure out the angle
measure in terms of radians
and you could figure out
the arc length of CD.
And I encourage you to pause the
video now and figure them out
on your own.
Well, let's work
through each of them.
We already figured out
that ab's length is 5x.
So we could just say that 5x
is going to be equal to 25/8.
Divide both sides by
5. x is equal to 5/8.
And so the measure of this
angle right here is 5/8 radians.
So what's going to be the
measure of this arc length?
So this is going
to be 9 times x.
That's just 45/8.